Let's go next to our caller from the three
one five area code, who is calling today from
three one five.
Hey, David.
What was it like for your parents to grow
up under the military government in Argentina?
Well, they I mean, so that's so my pet.
Very good question.
My parents did grow up.
I was born in Argentina shortly after the
end of the military regime in Argentina.
My parents in the 70s, you know, were young
adults, older teenagers and young adults in
the 70s, and they were leftists.
So, you know, imagine that you have a coffee
shop.
And this is a real example from my dad.
You have a cafe where the sort of left the
philosophy poly sci students are known to
hang out.
That becomes a place that is unsafe because
you've got informants of the military dictatorship.
You've got oppression being done by the military.
So, hey, that the cafe is no longer a safe
place for you to go and just chat with people.
My parents have friends who who were disappeared,
as the term is certainly, you know, killed.
So they were, you know, fortunately they were
OK, obviously.
I mean, they survived and I was born, but
they were in the thick of it.
They lost friends.
I think we've had we have extended family
that was killed and they were right in it.
I mean, they lived through a military dictatorship,
the likes of which is is inconceivable to
most American youth.
AK.
Hello.
Oh, boy.
All right, well, listen, I answered not not
clear what happened there, but appreciate
the phone call.